[Musique]
vous voulez représenter la tête pensante
du 11 septembre
mohamedou ould slahi les mauritaniens
détenus à guantanamo il a recruté les
types qui ont envoyé l'avion de votre
ami dans la tour sud
[Applaudissements]
nous ne sommes pas là pour des
interrogatoires nous travaillons
absolument pas pour le gouvernement
américain sait j'ai su que vous êtes
rentrée les interrogateurs nom par peur
d'être raisonné on va réclamer la peine
de mort mais si on omet un petit détail
il sera libéré le gouvernement américain
retient 700 prisonniers à guantanamo
depuis quand on enferme les gens sans
leur accorder de procès dans ce pays ça
fait un paquet de dossiers
oui le gouvernement à quatre en avance
sur nous
[Musique]
depuis que je suis ici on n'a cessé de
me dire tu es coupable pas pour quelque
chose que j'aurais fait mais à cause de
soupçons
le bureau du procureur refuse de nous
montrer les charges d'accusation tout
est censuré s'il ya un problème allez
voir le gouvernement
à
je suis innocent il a été interrogé et
il a été également retenu contre son gré
pendant six ans sans aucune charge
valable contre lui
ça ne vous perturbe pas de défendre un
terroriste ce n'est pas seulement lui
que je défends c'est la règle de droit
vous n'avez pas vu ce que j'ai vu
peut-être qu'il est coupable peut-être
oui
vous devez me dire tout ce que vous avez
subi sinon je ne pourrais pas vous
défendre et que vous comprenez vous
demander de mettre le feu ici mais moi
je suis toujours coincés ici ce n'est
pas un suspect c'est un témoin je viens
d'un pays où on n'a aucune confiance en
la police
jamais je n'aurais imaginé que les états
unis d'amérique utiliserait la peur et
la terreur pour me contrôler
[Musique]